do you know why the whole world hates a
clipper you're just a whiny little baby
who's far too slow on the flap are you
ashamed of me you are the former
first-team all-acc McDonald's
all-american Naismith prep Player of the
Year and you are my son I bet you need
whole new library just for all defensive
play
oh no no no none of that here I say the
defense taboo the offense
[Music]
Oh what happened to Lord Commander
are you okay he was attacked at the end
of the fourth quarter poor the Jester
all the rivers boy laughed I will break
their ankles neigh neigh neigh neighs
and the other attention I get it I mean
no violence is not the answer but
sometimes it is its funeral Chris you
know the gates of stables castle are
impregnable there are other ways here a
house clipper share their castle with
house lingo which means doubly fortified
walls they were then reinforced to
protect Coby from shock after his exile
and then re reinforce the protect Coby
with Dwight and then re re reinforce the
protect Coby been trying to unretire it
won't be easy
I'll need our best five so that's me
James Clint
Trevor Eric and Ryan wait no we need
someone expendable a journeyman you
what's your name green fur just signed
the tango they're in the stables Castle
has a secret back entrance a wheelchair
ramp built for sub Paul Pierce
synchronize your sundial
if you time it right we can slice
through their lazy zone defense at the
rear gates back to our car exactly but
we'll need a distraction that's where
you come in Clint from big ball arrows
Brad would you be interested in
purchasing some boots how much for the
shadows great choice what above the back
door is a small window that leads to
Donald Sterling's secret roost where he
would send his racist Ravens it's easy
to spot because all his birds were white
hoist me up and I'll sneak in and unlock
the door wait aren't you on house
Rockets
if you are please take me with you was
he taking so long do you think you got
cold
welcome to the stables castle once
inside we'll have to walk on eggshells
you see Sterling's roosters now the
chamber of Chuck the condor the most
horrifying mascot in the realm all right
now you lead the way
me why me do you want a guaranteed
contract
yeah but then Duke didn't go
that's journey me go oh no he's coming
back
[Applause]
hunting for fowls
it's what I do I don't know condors even
considered foul whoa
and one we then descend past Phil
Jackson Zen garden and into the shrine
to Kobe built by Kobe to honor himself
oh now what I don't know there supposed
to be a secret passageway James check
his closet
nothing just some skeletons Trevor okay
eight it's got to be eight wait hold on
another it could be five for each
champion
no it's 81 Kobe scored 81 sir Jalen the
knight of roses horse yes yes he values
individual accomplishments above all
others eight one
[Music]
Trevor are you okay I'm suspended go on
without me finish what we started
better him than us I suppose this will
take us to the lockers and sores
now in the event that we encountered the
Jester we implement operation general
thanks for coming out so much Squire
here some of the older blogs take me to
a whorehouse
can't I just cross him up or something
James we've been through this
you were wine and how and the gods would
be all over us it's true
no one can wine like Blake he's the best
second best second best sorry all right
on with the dress and off with the beard
I don't know it's not just a beard I am
the beard do it for Lord Commander
goodbye old friend
European Apes and your pubes you look
stunning
I just I don't know if I can do this
don't worry James instead of acting like
you're getting fouled just act like
kendall Jenner hey baby
Kendal what are you doing here I came
here to dunk I'm Emmy talk but but I'm
at work
well you haven't been rebound you
haven't been responding to my Ravens I
don't think you sent me any Ravens I was
gyro stepping I mean I was Europe
modelling I mean I was in Europe I was
modeling in Europe you see I'm an
influencer model Kendra are you okay
sorry lately I've been feeling a little
beard I mean a feeling little weird
I'm James hearted I mean I'm Kendall
kardashian-jenner that's when I make the
move
usually during something I should have
done a long time ago gotcha [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]